[Music]
egg that is not the usual thievery zip -
dear Hank and John do you know what you
just heard it was chipmunks right now
Hank you are listening to the dulcet
tones of the Chipmunks singing their hit
song there's no rock and roll on Mars so
while we were at nerdcon nerdfighteria
we met up with John Harrison a
nerdfighter who we've known for a while
now and he gave me an LP Hank an LP a
vinyl record of the chipmunk singing hit
songs from their television program
including their hit song there's no rock
and roll on Mars John when you say hit
song uh did this one chart I don't know
I feel like I heard this one before is
it one of the greatest songs ever
recorded by the chipmunks yes has it
been like culturally acknowledged as one
of the greatest chipmunk songs not yet
but that's what this podcast is here to
do Hank it is here to turn Alvin and the
Chipmunks singing there's no rock and
roll on Mars into the hit that it
deserves to be yeah trying to get them
the proper credibility I will say though
that John in the chipmunks coloring book
which I have just found a picture of on
deviantART Alvin Simon and Theodore are
playing soccer on Mars while singing
there's no rock and roll on Mars because
there is no beat among the stars but
they have gone to Mars so they think
that it's worth going despite the lack
of rock and roll I am a little bit
skeptical of the moon that is in the sky
in this drawing of the chipmunks because
uh there's no there's no moon like that
on Mars either but good try of chipmunk
coloring book illustration good try they
seem to be having a very good time well
I wanted to thank John for the LP as
well as for his friendship and I hope
that
you're enjoying the pod Hank let's start
up the proper podcast now I guess hello
and welcome this is dear Hank and John
your comedy podcast about death we're
gonna answer your questions provide your
dubious advice bring you all the week's
news from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon
but first first I have to read a short
poem Hank or actually let's talk about
how we're doing how was nerdcon for you
right it was great my voice is still a
little bit raw and hopefully I won't be
coughing too much I sang my soul out of
my mouth and it got out for a little bit
but then I got it back because everybody
threw it back to me a crowd-surf for a
while and and it was fantastic it really
was magical it made me so excited for
VidCon Europe and Amsterdam this April
and for VidCon this summer and it just I
have to say Hank you know you do a lot
of things and sometimes I get
overwhelmed with the number of things
that you do because I have to be new too
I have to be the tail to your comet and
even being that can be a little
exhausting but this weekend at nerdcon I
was reminded that you and the people you
work with just put together amazing
experiences and I felt so grateful to be
there and I'm very grateful to you and I
will stop being sentimental now but I am
really excited to see you again in
Amsterdam and then in Anaheim and
presumably maybe we'll hang out at some
point not in front of thousands of
people Hank would you like a short poem
for today yeah do it oh one other thing
that's going on in my life as we're
recording this it's Ash Wednesday mm-hmm
sure
it's the beginning of Lent for me and
lots of other people and I've decided to
give up the social Internet for Lent
tank and so far it's great yeah I give
up the social internet for baby and it
was all it was great and in fact just
this weekend like because there's so
much going on in the real life at a
convention I you sort of like by default
kind of you know give up on like at
least consuming Twitter and stuff like I
might be posting tweets just because
like I like I'm I'm having exceptionally
interesting things happen to me but I
don't read them and then I like and that
when I get back into it I'm like wow why
was I doing this before this doesn't
this isn't better and and suddenly the
the Donald Trump is giving a speech to
Congress and
like I don't care like the the thing
that happened right this moment has
absolutely like there are so many days
that have happened why do I care what's
happening on this particular day well I
don't not answer that question Hank
except to say that maybe you should
embrace Christianity at least enough to
embrace Lent I feel like if I was gonna
give up something for Lent it would be
say would be maybe a I don't know what
would it be maybe I should give up I can
think about that while I read you a
short poem if you'd like yeah sure you
go all right Hank here's a short poem
for today it's just it's one of my
favorites very short but very beautiful
it goes like this
he's traveled near and far yes he's come
a long long way and if you ask him why
he's come here this is what he'll say
there's no rock and roll on Mars
there's no beat among the stars as you
can plainly see the earth is the place
to be because there's no rock and roll
on Mars I see you know that that was a
oh god it's just you know it's
everything I wanted for him to be it's
funny it's heart-wrenching actually I
was older Lee in and I just thought it
was just another poem
it's pretty amazing poetry I mean all
the the hidden gems that are in amongst
the the works of the chipmunks John
question or should I
why don't you ask the first question
Hank this one is from Rachel who asks
dear Hank and John my friend and I were
driving the other day and she since she
was in the passenger seat she said that
she should get the aux cord and play her
music however I believe that since I am
the one who was going through the
stressful process of driving I deserve
to listen to the music who deserves the
aux cord please
help settle this debate of auxin and aux
chords Rachel hmm it's a tough one
I do think that in general the drivers
needs need to be prioritized right but
at the same time like you Rachel when
you're driving you shouldn't be trying
to figure out what songs are gonna play
like if it's just like your friend is is
plugging in the thing no but you should
be able to say to your friend yeah well
I feel like maybe it's your iPod it's a
selection of your music but I don't want
you distracted by figuring out what
songs to play I but but I do think that
in general not only are you driving it
is presumably your vehicle and so your
friend is the one I mean unless you have
a shared vehicle you it's your car you
decide yeah yeah a hundred percent
Rachel it's your iPod that goes into
this aux cord or phone or whatever the
kids are listening to music on these
days but then your friend gets to pick
which songs from your oh wait no people
don't have songs on their phones anymore
now they just have streaming services so
you'd be opening your friend up to
listen to literally anything they could
listen to as my son likes to the lesser
known hits of the rapper sigh so I think
you have to have veto power over what
songs are played I have to say Hank I'm
part of part of what makes this question
difficult for me is that my children
think that they have a right to listen
to whatever music they want to listen to
when they're in the car with me and what
they want to listen to almost
exclusively is this song by psy called
daddy are you familiar with it no John I
am not familiar with Vani okay so it's
one of Psy's lesser-known works and it
is like it's I I mean I know that sighs
have listener to the pod so I want to be
clear that I'm a big fan of his work and
I'm grateful to him and obviously that
that song has 240 million listen so
somebody likes it it's horrible and like
McVie do is kind of funny but I can't I
can't watch the music video in the car
I'm just listening to the song over and
over and over I've probably heard the
song I would lowball it at six hundred
billion times I am responsible for
almost all of the listens to Daddy that
have ever happened in the world and it's
oh my god
oh my god if I and they just think oh
it's our car but it's not it's my car
right yes do you should you should
definitely you should definitely before
you let your children in the car
have them sign a piece of paper that
says this is not my car or just have
them say it out loud because I don't
know if they can write yet but just say
say daddy this is not my car yeah
yeah Alice can't really Alice can't
really sign her name yet as such but I
mean on general they just I love my
children but they don't have great taste
in music at the moment which is weird
cuz like you would think that since I'm
pretty into the chipmunks yeah like we
could maybe find some common ground but
somehow we can't hey we've got another
question this one comes from Ryan
apparently he's a real Ryan although I
have not seen a driver's license so it's
impossible to know for sure but Ryan
writes Dear John and Hank since the
universe is expanding what does that
mean for the space that we occupy am I
getting larger and weighs unrelated to
weight gain why do we not notice that we
are all inflating like balloons nouns
and other nouns Ryan yes Ryan which
sounds like something someone not named
Ryan would say although I'm inclined to
believe that this is a Ryan in the
future if you want to email us and get
your question answered the first thing
you want to be is a rhyme and you want
to be able to definitely identify
yourself as a Ryan in some way that's
extremely compelling to us yes you go
you can go ahead and send proof along
that'd be absolutely fine now the
question we got a lot of false Ryan's oh
so so situation John it's universe is
expanding but we we are not is that okay
with you uh it seems wrong do you need
it explained didn't you need to explain
more deeply than that I thought I was
part of the universe you are part of the
universe but the universe is expanding
but the the forces that hold atoms
together are not changing and so they
the atoms are held together as tightly
and in the same size and all of the
other chemical and atomic interactions
are happening on a much different scale
and also gravity and also all of these
forces they happen that those forces
stay the same so the universe is
expanding but individual elements of the
universe are not expanding are some
individual elements that the universe
expands well I mean basically if
something is traveling apart like like
things that are moving apart from each
other they they move differently than
they would if the you
verse weren't expanding because goodness
I'd this above my paygrade John the like
like so galaxies seem to stay the same
size pretty much but super clusters
which are like galaxies of galaxies like
big clusters of galaxies they are
expanding a little bit but they don't
expand as much as they with as the
universe is because the group there's
gravity holding them together so it's
really the space like the the space
between the galaxies that we can really
see expanding because there isn't there
like because the the things between but
with that stuff in between them are so
far apart that they basically don't
affect each other anymore and so you can
really see the effect of the expanse of
the universe but again not really a
thing I know so one of the things that I
like to think about when I really want
my head to hurt is that there are a
hundred billion stars in our galaxy the
Milky Way or somewhere around there and
there are at least 100 billion galaxies
in the universe
so like our neighborhood has a hundred
billion stars which is one neighborhood
out of 100 billion neighborhoods so that
makes me feel like like that like III
definitely get how stuffs happening on a
few different scales you know like well
in general like we've realized things
about the universe that are like oh okay
let's just maybe we should just think
about what's happening here because it
would we look up there it's like oh wow
that's weird
that's super cool it's super cool but I
don't want to think about it too much
because it makes me wonder like what's
where what am i and do I like Wow okay
that's uh that's outside of the scale of
our ability to really comprehend yeah
like one of the ones that I'm fond of is
that it doesn't really do any good to
think about what happened before the Big
Bang because there was no time at least
as we understand it so whatever there
was no before the Big Bang because time
started then right brought that's such a
bit like two like two
me from not coming from a science
background coming from like a humanities
background that's such a cop-out to be
like oh no you don't understand the Big
Bang also created time well like that
I'm sure that's true but it's too weird
for me to accept but it does really
sound like like oh you wanted to know
this answer this question oh well that
thing doesn't exist there's no answer to
that question ha ha ha
done yeah it's like the it's like the
Zen masters used to say that there's no
answer to the question because it's a
question wrongly put I have a related
question there for you Hank
which also might be a question wrongly
put for all I know this question comes
from Meghan who writes dear green
brothers recently in a scishow video
Hank mentioned the Big Bang and
reference to it creating radio wave
interfering waves that still exists to
this day I could have sworn that I read
somewhere that the Big Bang was
disproven as a possible theory to how
our universe of galaxies came to be I
know that for religious reasons some
people don't believe in the Big Bang and
perhaps they could have spread this but
I thought it was disproven by scientists
I guess my question would have to be Big
Bang do you believe it happened and has
it been disproven simply Meghan I again
above my paygrade there continues to be
discussion we based on sort of like what
we based on the available data it seems
very very very likely that the Big Bang
was a thing like we can see the evidence
of it having happened we like everything
is radiating out from from like a
central point kind of and if you trace
all that back then then it indeed looks
like it traces back to a moment when
everything was sort of compressed into
an infinitesimally tiny little piece of
space and super super super hot piece of
space and like sexy yeah this very very
attractive to to the average you know
and um super symmetrical features so I
don't know where the I mean things
happen occasionally where we're like oh
we have new data and it doesn't fit in
with a big bang or it even contradicts
the Big Bang hypothesis and then we have
to be like ok what does that mean for
the Big Bang should we be
stammering that theory which explains a
lot of stuff or should we trying to
figure out whether this data is wrong or
whether this data adds will add to our
understanding of you know our
understanding of cosmology but no it was
not disproven do I believe it is a weird
question because I don't like I'd try
not to think that I believe in any of
these things I tried to think that like
these are the current best explanations
we have for the data we have collected
and and I had tried out not have that be
about belief but no it has not been
disproven though it is very difficult to
disprove anything we can say that a lot
of the data that we have is explained
very well by the idea of the Big Bang
all right thank you one ask a question
that's not about science yeah sure this
question comes from Kayla who asks dear
Hank and John this past year has been
particularly rough for me and I've been
dealing with some pretty unpleasant
bouts of depression as of about an hour
ago I've booked a plane ticket to spend
two weeks in Amsterdam by myself to kind
of try and find myself I've really
wanted to go to Amsterdam after hearing
John speaks so highly of it so John this
one is for you what are the things a
person must see and experience in
Amsterdam also any tips for a 25 year
old woman traveling by herself champagne
and bitter balls Kayla all right Kayla
first off I love the geographical cure
as a solution to all all problems it
never works but I keep trying I've been
trying it for most of my life it's
always failed but I'm gonna keep after
it because I believe in the geographical
cure so Hank I once went to my somewhat
hometown of Birmingham Alabama for two
weeks I decided to go there to find
myself in my mid-20s during a really bad
period of mental health I was going to
go back to my high school haunts and
walk that world and try to work on the
story that was looking for Alaska and
etc and so I got a room at the motel 6
near my old high school for I think 13
consecutive nights and do you know what
I did and just sit around and watch TV I
did not leave the hotel room for them
for those 13 days that is that was a bad
strategy in retrospect spending 13 days
inside of the motel 6 in Pelham Alabama
did not significantly improve my mental
health so Kayla I would encourage you to
try not to do that to try to before you
go maybe build some kind of social
network so there are some people you can
meet up with maybe nerdfighters that you
can meet up with maybe fellow listeners
to the pod maybe connect to people on
the nerdfighter discord channel I don't
know what the best way is or some other
travel forum because I think if you can
meet people or have things that you want
to do that aren't just tourist things
that'll really help get you through the
two weeks so that you don't become
further and further isolated there are a
few things that I see even if you're
going to VidCon Europe in Amsterdam and
you want to have some fun things to do
there are a few things I really really
love doing in Amsterdam one is if you
can drink I highly recommend going to
this bar where there are like 400
different kinds of the Dutch national
liquor univer it's I don't know how to
pronounce anything in Dutch despite
having spent a lot of time there I think
it's called a pro flick all why nerd
[ __ ] but it doesn't matter just
Google Dutch genever place in Amsterdam
and you'll get there there's also great
museums in Amsterdam the Anne Frank
House obviously but also the steadily is
one of the best contemporary art museums
in the world
the Rijksmuseum has an incredible
collection of Dutch masters Renaissance
and Renaissance painting the central
library in Amsterdam is one of the most
architectural interesting libraries have
ever been in a wonderful place to write
and think and read they have a pretty
good English language section as well
and then I just loved every morning
walking around the Vondelpark which is
like Amsterdam Central Park it is a big
open public space full of lots of
interesting people watching but also you
know a nice cafe and la it's just a
really cool park so I recommend that and
you can spend all day in Amsterdam if
you
just walking you know the canal streets
and people watching and stopping in
cafes and enjoying cups of coffee and
since it takes 45 minutes for anyone to
bring you a check you would be surprised
how quickly you can kill the day by
having one cup of coffee
so those recommendations the big thing I
would say you have to flag them down
yeah hat like in Europe if you want to
leave a restaurant you have to be hello
I am over here and I would like to no
longer be in your restaurant they don't
just come to you yeah it doesn't yeah at
one point during our months and
Amsterdam
I did get up at a restaurant walk up to
the front and do a very ugly American
thing which was saying I am going to
leave I would like to pay for my meal
but regardless I am going to leave yeah
I just I I do want to just encourage you
one more time gala go to try to make
sure that you're creating a situation
where you're not going to stay like
inside your hostel for 14 days feeling
really sad because that might not help
out so good luck with your geographical
cure I still believe in it despite all
my failures yes quite III will add a
very small thing which is that I find
museums to be terrible unless I do a
like a fair amount of research first
I think museums are more or less built
for people who know stuff about the
thing that is inside of the museum and
so when I when I go to like when I go to
museums of science I'm just like this is
the coolest and when I go to museums of
art I'm like this ah my hands feel like
they're going to explode because my
blood has stopped pumping in my lymph is
no longer being pushed around my body
because of the sheer crushing weight of
not knowing any of the context of any of
this stuff and so I have now found that
if I can spend like even a half hour
reading about the museum and some of the
stuff that's inside of it before going
to it I feel much less like I hate it
fair enough
uh you've got another question or do you
want me to hit you with one John I I
mean I there's a huge variety of
questions here Hank I can ask you a
question you can ask me a question we
could just end the pod whatever you feel
well I got it I got another one that I
would it's for you John and but it's
about me so I want to ask it it's from
Liesl who asks dear Hank and John my
name is Liesl and I've been a
nerdfighter for nigh on eight or nine
years big fan of your content when I get
ready in the morning sometimes I have
old blog where there's YouTube videos
playing in the background recently what
two of the videos I watched where Hank
giving videos directed towards John's
children why is this guy blue and how to
be a baby properly have Henry and Alice
seen any of these videos or any
vlogbrothers videos and John when will
you make a video providing your nephew
with arbitrary and probably dubious
advice more morituri te salutant
morituri te salutant lethal which who
knows you know what that sign off means
Hank does it mean remember you must die
no it means those who are about to die
salute you it's something that the Roman
legions used to say to pare Caesar
pretty good those who are about to die
salute you oh I'll tell you what the
Romans knew so much about how to die
dramatically now cuz John but it works
for everybody because we're all about to
die I know I actually think those who
are about to die salute you is a really
great sign off and I would encourage
more people to use it if memento mori
doesn't work for you maybe morituri te
salutant will so Hank I do not think I
have shown either of those videos to
Henry or Alice I have watched a few
vlogbrothers videos they aren't super
into them they like watching yours more
than they like watching mine certainly
and maybe if I showed them some
kid-friendly vlogbrothers content they
would be into it but they like their own
YouTube you know YouTube kids is its own
little world yeah well I guess I should
probably make some animated minecraft
machinima and be very excited
I mean if you wanted to make some like
Minecraft videos Henry would watch that
all day
I am not exaggerating
[Laughter]
well I just I have to make sure that
their educational is well that probably
will make Henry like them less that is
the thing about it isn't it and indeed I
want to ask another question this one
comes from Xenia who asks dear junk
sorry I don't wanna have to choose a
favorite that's that's a class way of
approaching it my name is Xenia and I'm
19 and I'm from Germany writing you from
India I just watched the video uploaded
yesterday on February 14th but by the
way never trust that your question will
be answered in a timely fashion
concerning development and how the
overall quality of life is increasing
rapidly due to international development
efforts I've noticed that we as a
society often tend to see ourselves in
my case Germany or Europe as the end
goal as if we have all the answers one
idea that was introduced to us today was
the model of two-dimensional development
which tries to find a balance between
the factors we have considered to be
important for development and the impact
a country has on the environment my
question is is it not about time that we
change the way we talk about development
how can we consider ourselves to be a
developed country when our love for
consumption could irreparable ii destroy
the world we all live in referring to
countries has developed or developing
implies that the former have reached the
ultimate goal while the latter strive to
reach that standard so I think this is a
really interesting question Hank and I
wanted to ask it because it brings up
important points and I do think that
there's something deeply wrong with
talking about developed and developing
countries some people have started to
use different phrases like rich
countries poor countries and
middle-income countries which also comes
with its own set of problems because you
know it presumes that that rich is the
only good end but that said just as I
think we have to be really careful when
it comes to not imposing our definitions
of success upon other communities I also
think we have to listen to other
communities when they talk about the
ways in which they want life to change
in their communities and one of the
things that and and so and so to me that
is the key to development is listening
and and I think across cultures one of
the things you find consistently
is that people don't want their kids to
die that they don't want to die in
childbirth that they don't want
disabling diseases and that they want
their families to have enough food and
access to the right nutrients as well as
shelter and that you do find pretty much
everywhere people want to have long
healthy productive lives and they want
their kids to have access to education
and so when those are the focus foci or
focuses I don't actually know which is
the right word of development efforts I
think that they are good and I don't
want to tell other people that
consumption is only for countries that
are currently rich instead I want to
create you know a world where because we
have far more people who are better
educated that means we have far more
innovators who can solve big difficult
problems like the problem of energy for
instance and I also don't want to say
that only certain kinds of development
should be available to other people you
know like I think there's something a
little bit wrong and paternalistic about
saying like oh only we should be allowed
to be disgustingly conspicuous consumers
I think that that's equally problematic
well it's not just it's not like the
conspicuousness of the consumption I
mean you look back at the history of
America and we destroyed our landscape
we have been very inefficient and then
we say to other countries don't do that
don't use the resources on your land
leave them in place
don't don't strip mine don't do all the
things all the things that we did in
order to build our economy and yes like
we want to create a world where that
those things don't happen but it's also
like we are are literally right you and
me and most of the people listen to this
podcast right now are probably literally
sitting upon a thing that was the result
of like of that exploitation of the
natural world and and so when I when I
talk about like the environment and
climate change oftentimes people will be
like well how could you also be like in
favor of cap
ilysm and it's because like we like
there's the environment and then there's
humans and I believe that those both of
those things are important and we have
to create solutions for human beings who
are in terrible situations in who are
suffering and that is important it is
also important that we preserve an
environment that will continue to be
able to sustain humanity and also
preferably other things well for their
own sake well into the future and that's
hard that's hard problems to solve and
and well and I don't think but I don't
think that like we can say like don't do
that without also coming with a solution
to help them to help people grow the you
know the opportunities for them and
their their children their families
without doing whatever that thing is
right and I think one of the ways we're
gonna find solutions to those problems
is that right now we have not come even
close to maximizing the number of
potential innovators on earth among
humans because we because the vast
majority of people don't have access to
really good educational opportunities
and so I think with more kids in schools
and more kids in school for longer I
think that you can create a virtuous
cycle in which some of these energy
problems can be if not solved then at
least mitigated and you know that that
we may look back on this time as the
time when we hopefully became highly
motivated to solve these energy and
consumption problems and also started to
have the human resources to solve them
yeah but it is very complicated and it
is not easy and I think it is important
to consider all the things that markets
don't do well and one of the things that
markets do especially poorly is value
natural resources well John I've got
another question if you think that it's
time for that it's from Elsa who asks
dear Hank dear Hank and John when they
send people to Mars in 2028 or earlier
by the way Elsa do you think they will
only send people of one gender what
would happen if somebody got pregnant on
Mars what would we do would with a baby
be an alien would it stay there please
answer this can't wait spaceships and
aliens el
Elsa it can't it can wait
take it away it cannot that last 11
years this cannot wait and in fact I
believe that there was just a movie
about this topic that didn't do
particularly well but yes we will send
people of both genders to Mars
there has been some little bit of
discussion about how it would be better
to send only women to Mars because they
tend to be smaller and thus easier to
shoot through space and also they
consume fewer calories and you know I
loved all else being equal it's good to
have good to be shooting less stuff
through the space than more stuff so
maybe we'll just take a bunch of small
people but but we will send both genders
because we want to study the effects of
space and life on Mars on both genders
because the like the big one of the big
great things about going to Mars is that
you can not only have humans on the
surface of Mars studying Mars you can
have those people then come home and get
studied and you can have them on the
surface of Mars studying each other to
make sure that we can indeed
successfully and healthfully live on the
surface of another planet
Wow but I imagine everybody's gonna be
on birth control yep that's the end of
that question would it be hard to would
it be hard to have a baby on Mars uh I
you know John I don't know that it would
be any harder to have the baby on Mars
though certainly we have no idea it
would definitely be very like
problematic and worrying for the the
development of the baby once it's born
and I would would not oh really
would not want to do that without I
don't know I without without like animal
testing frankly I I we have no idea what
so you're saying that Mars is not a good
place to raise children I'm saying Mars
is not a good place to have children and
it's not the kind of place to raise your
kids in fact it's cold as hell so well
that seems to me like a place that I
don't want to go why would I want to go
somewhere it's not even gonna be a good
good place yeah it is
like like let's stay here we've never
had which is a great place to raise
children in fact it's the best place in
the known universe to raise children by
four we've never actually I don't know
if we've done experiments on animals who
are pregnant in space but I bet we have
so write to us about that well I'm about
to Google pregnant animals in space and
become a expert in this field
boom space born animals adjust to
gravity from 2013 boom it was a
jellyfish they took jellyfish to space
some of those jellyfish were pregnant
and their jellyfish children were born
and raised in zero gravity and
everything worked out better than
expected so we'll be fine I I think that
you know what they say what goes for
jellyfish always goes for humans we do
it with rats too but this article is
very long and I'm not gonna read it
right now it has a quote from the Maine
scientists quote I was exposed to the
space bug and I got it bad I don't know
if that's a reference to like when they
were in space and they had some kind of
flu but it sounds terrible I've always
wanted space bugs at all cost
god I'm so entirely content to stay here
on the planet Earth and just explore its
majesty
alright hey I got another question for
you are you ready I'm ready are you
still reading about pregnant rats good
space rats pregnant space rats is a
pretty good name for a band this
question should I take it to a real
serious place or should I just should we
just keep going with the current vibe
well let's let's switch it up John
switch me hard swerve ok we're going to
a real serious place this question comes
from Joshua who asks dear John and Hank
you're both married and seem very happy
and very much in love with your spouse's
I am also married but I do not love my
wife I don't hate her or anything I just
don't love her how do I deal with this
additional details we have three kids
together and I feel resentful of them
almost like it's their fault I don't
love my wife even though I know it isn't
we're just really good roommates at this
point sorry I
have a cool sign-off Joshua I think you
might need to go to therapy I think like
you should go to therapy because I think
probably a lot of what's happening is
maybe not about your children or your
spouse but about stuff that's happening
with you and I wouldn't like discount
also going to therapy with your spouse
right I would do both if you have access
to a good mental health care yeah I mean
the therapist could help you develop a
cool sign-off but I think that there are
more substantial worries at this point I
think we've got three problems the first
problem and the one that's probably
easiest to solve this not having a cool
sign-off problem because we've we've
just discovered one right yes in this in
this very episode of dear Hank and John
so you can just say we who are about to
die salute you that's that problem is
solved so then we've got these we've got
two somewhat larger more complicated
problems the resentfulness toward the
kids which I mean everybody feels
resentful toward their kids sometimes
but you don't want to not have that like
joy and pleasure in your life but I also
think um yeah I mean obviously do not
come to us for psychological help or for
counseling Hank and I are so far outside
of the world of relationship experts it
is not even funny we know absolutely
nothing about this I will say that I
don't think that love is some like place
that you arrive at and never leave I
don't really buy that vision of love
that it's this thing that you're
supposed to feel all the time like that
you know like the room that there's when
I was in my Catholic engaged encounter
Hank before Sarah and I got married we
went on this one week-long Catholic
engaged encounter that despite me hating
every second of it has had a huge and
positive influence on my life and when
we were on our Catholic engaged
encounter they told us that love goes
through this cycle of romance
disillusionment and content and I found
that very helpful because when I'm
experiencing disillusionment or content
I tend not to think like oh well this is
forever I tend to think like well here
we are in the cycle
and that's been very helpful to me
thanks for thanks for throwing the
swerve in John I've got to keep it
interesting here on dear Hank and John
speaking of the swerve Hank that reminds
me today's podcast is brought to you by
the swerve the swerve a part of the
podcast Hank just invented this podcast
is also brought to you by the song daddy
by psy it's got a real great music video
and you want to hear it over and over
and over again in your car's real nice
sound system I really actually I
genuinely wish the song daddy by psy
would at least sponsor me so I could get
some money out of this horrible horrible
deal I found myself in of course today's
podcast is also sponsored by the
geographical Cure the geographical Kure
it hasn't worked yet but it but who
cares because you get to go places this
podcast is also brought to you by the
Big Bang Theory not the television show
the actual system for explaining a bunch
of data that we have that is the best
current explanation that we've come up
with wouldn't be great if the Big Bang
could actually sponsor us either the
television program or the concept
wouldn't it be great if we had like a
regular sponsor like blue plate or
whatever the hell it is that people have
the food uncooked come to their house
twice a week and then they apply the
heat to it
maybe some day Hank maybe some day you
know what I like we should we should
make our own one of those and call it
the food uncooked hears that we've got
an incredible new concept for you what
we do is we send you groceries we mark
them up quite a bit we send you
groceries and then you turn it into food
or or or or it's the food cooked and
it's a it's this local except okay
here's what it is it's a building in
your town a place where you can go
inside and they will give you cooked
food and it's called the food cooked
it's like blue apron but you go to a
place instead of coming to you and the
food is already cooked I have to say I
actually use one of those services
plated and it's freakin amazing
I love faded so I shouldn't make too
much fun of blue apron because I it's
not that different but man we use plated
twice a week and it just
it allows us to have dinner together to
like make dinner together I'm sorry it
is a good experience stop it
wait until they sponsor us oh okay I
will I will wait until they sponsor us I
plated I await your thousands and
thousands of dollars I was gonna say
hundreds but I'm not selling myself
short anymore Hank before we get to the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon we have
some corrections and responses that are
very important that we need to discuss
number one we received an email from
Lang who is an actual mammoth
paleobiologist we should just oh gosh
the mammoth things still happen demanda
thing is still happening here's the
thing I I said that I was happy I did
not live with mammoths because I like
being at the top of the food chain
however mammoths and mastodons were both
herbivores so they would have had no
interest in eating me and I want to
apologize to all the mammoths and
mastodons out there I'm not totally sure
whether you guys are extinct actually
but if you aren't I'm really sorry
because that was an unfair
characterization of you can we really
really quickly just end all discussion
of mammoths and mastodons before we get
something else wrong great point
couple responses that we need to get to
lots of people wrote in to say that
capitalism is not objectively better
than other systems which is maybe true I
don't know all we know is that Hank and
I are not economists also also lorraine
eroded to respond to our statement that
the USA is the only really powerful
country in which you would want to live
and the only really powerful country
that you would want to rule the world
she wrote as follows you guys answered
this question about how the USA is the
only powerful country you'd want to live
in and i admit that sometimes i forget
about how you still have this huge
american pride so suddenly i got a
little sad cuz i look up to you so much
but I think that the USA is one of the
meanest and most annoying countries out
there
it helped military governments in Latin
America and we still suffer from this
there is there are more reasons but that
one strikes me the most yeah I would
rather have my country be influenced by
Finland Norway or Denmark than the US a
Brazilian girl and frustration Lorena
Lorena I want
be absolutely clear about something we
would also rather have the world be
influenced by Finland Norway or Denmark
we just weren't counting Finland Norway
or Denmark
in our category of powerful countries I
think Hank and I were thinking of three
countries China Russia and the United
yes also you are absolutely right that
the United States has been a foreign
policy disaster in Latin America for a
long time yeah and full stop I'll stop
but yes please Norway become the most
powerful country in the world start
spending 34 percent of their GDP on
defense and please just take a sofa hey
they got a pretty good army there in
Norway I think they have compulsory
service there's also an email from
Madeline Hank that I wanted to get to
because it just as the favorite my
favorite quote that I've read in many
years she writes dear John and Hank not
seeing not I'm not seeking dubious
advice I was just listening to your
discussion about how activism can be a
frustratingly long process and it made
me want to share something I found
recently in all of Shriners 1911 book
women and labor I'm just gonna read you
this quote Hank because I think it may
stick with some of our listeners the way
it's stuck with me and and with Madeline
I would like to say to the men and women
of the generations which will come after
us you will look back at us with
astonishment you will wonder at
passionate struggles that accomplished
so little at the to you obvious paths to
attain our ends which we did not take at
the intolerable evils before which it
will seem to you we sat down passive at
the great truths staring us in the face
which we failed to see at the great
truths we grasped at but could not get
our fingers quite round you will marvel
at the labor that ended in so little but
what you will never know is how it was
thinking of you and for you that we
struggled as we did and accomplished the
little which we have done that it was in
the thought of your larger realization
and fuller life that we have found
consolation for the futilities of our
own all I aspire to be and was not
comforts me huh I just thought that was
fantastic
uh-huh that's good that's it that's all
I just wanted to read that Thank You
Madeline for setting that in thanks to
ever
buddy who emailed us at all the things
we didn't respond to I'm so sorry but
hey but we have to get to the news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon that's right John
now we got some news from Mars it's a
paper published in in the journal Nature
and I'm just gonna read you the abstract
because that because I can and you and I
know you want to hear it
abstract a major knowledge gap exists on
how Repticon positions of a single
Martian volcano province change over
time here we seek to fill that gap by
assessing the compositional evolution of
Elysium a major Martian volcanic
province a unique geo chemical signature
overlaps with the southern flows of this
volcano which provides the context for
this study of variability of Martian
magnet magnetism the southeastern lava
fields of Elysium Polynesia showed
distinct chemistry in the shallow
subsurface down to several decimeters
relative to the rest of the Martian mid
to low latitudes average crust and flows
in the north northwest Elysium by impact
crater accounting chronology we
estimated the age of the southeastern
province to be 0.5 plus or minus 0.08 GA
younger than the northwestern fields
this study of the geochemical and
temporal differences between the
northwestern and south with southeastern
elysium lava fields is the first to
demonstrate compositional variation
within a single volcanic province on
mars we interpret the geochemical and
temporal differences between the
southeast and northwest lava fields to
be consistent with primary magmatic
processes such as mantle heterogeneity
or change in depth of melt formation
within the martian mantle due to crustal
loading it's very exciting John oh
that's great the best part about that is
that nobody's gonna hear the news from
AFC Wimbledon because everybody turned
off the plot what did that I mean can
you tell me in a sentence what that
meant or will it just become more
annoying
it basically basically means that this
one one volcanic area of Mars has have
has lava flows from different time
periods oh wow that is exciting
well the most important third tier
soccer team in England and arguably the
world AFC Wimbledon so Hank you'll
recall that last week when we podcasted
live from nerdcon nerdfighteria AFC
wimbledon had just defeated Walsall
thanks to a goal from the Messi for
Montserrat Lyle Taylor and that meant
that AFC Wimbledon had climbed up the
table a bit closer towards safety
remember it's 52 points over the last 20
years
every team with at least 52 points at
the end of the season has not been
relegated from Ligue 1 so that is the
that is the goal point total at the
moment and that put us on 43 points and
then we had an away game against
Scunthorpe
Scunthorpe currently second in the
league very likely to go up to the
championship the second tier of English
football next year and that away game
against Scunthorpe it looked terrible
because not only were we playing a team
ranked very highly also we were playing
a team that generally is very good at
home and furthermore AFC Wimbledon had
not won an away game since October mmm
but Hank hope is the thing with feathers
and then you lost the game and AFC
Wimbledon emerged 2-1 Victor's over
hearts we won a game away from home in
2017 it was it was incredible it was
thrilling it was everything that you
could want it to be AFC Wimbledon went
up 1 nil the Dom Polian scored a goal
and then I think he did it anyway and
then and then he's definitely scored the
second goal and Scunthorpe scored a goal
in like the 85th minute but it was not
enough AFC Wimbledon 2-1 Victor's
suddenly from from a nervous making
position 40 points after 32 games
suddenly AFC Wimbledon are back in 12th
place 46 points after 34 games now just
six points away from that magical number
52 and afraid at this point honestly
looking up the table more than looking
down right look up that table just the
way that those scientists are looking
on the Elysium Polynesia of Mars to
determine the geographical and temporal
specificities of Martian volcanoes John
I want to correct myself the first goal
was scored by Dean parrot
Oh Thank You mr. parrot Thank You mr.
parrot we appreciate your goals and hegg
thank you for potting with me it's
always a pleasure John I had a good time
and I feel bad for all the things that
we didn't get to answer dear Hank and
John is produced by rosianna halse rojas
and Sheridan Gibson our editor is
Nicholas Jenkins Victoria bon giorno is
our head of community and communications
and our music is by the great gunnarolla
you can contact us at Hank and John at
gmail.com
we are Hank green and John Green on
Twitter is the hashtag dear Hank and
John if you would like to send us stuff
that way we're on patreon at patreon.com
slash dear Hank and John and we are also
living on the surface of the best planet
on which to raise your children that's
right can't beat it can't beat it thanks
for watching thanks thanks for watching
this visually fascinating podcast thanks
for listening and as we say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]